في الليره الاخيره من شهر ابريل سكان
والسياح في السويد على موعد مع ليله النار
احتفال كبير في كل المدن لطرد الارواح
الشريره والاحتفال بالربيع الليله
فاربورغيس كما يطلق عليها هي في الاصل
احياء لذكرى القديسه فالبوركا التي عاشت
في القرن الثامن الميلادي ويتم الاحتفال
بها في اجزاء من شمال اوروبا والدول
الاسكندنافيه ففي المانيا مثلا يرتدي
المحتفلون ازياء الصحراء والاقنعه المخيفه
وفي التشيك يقوم المشاركون بادرام النار
في دميه تمثل شخصيات الصحراء اما في
استونيا فتعتبر هذه الليله واحدا من
الاحتفالات الشائعه والمهمه الاستقبال فصل
الربيع في البلاد يمثل الليل لديه من لقاء
بالساحرات وخلاله يرتدي المحتفلون نفس
الملابس المخيفه ويجوبون الشوارع باجواء
احتفاليه فرحا بانتهاء فصل الشتاء